pitov resisted this prizes about seeing
the invisible can you tell us something
more about this priority am I your
electron microscope I think it's a
revolution because now it's possible to
extract molecules from the cell that are
in in the same environment as they're
usually in a Cell in in the water and
not also see the structures of these
molecules but also see how they interact
with each other how how they operate one
can get since the other particles
molecules that are studied are in
solution they are frozen in a different
state and one can then combine the
different pictures to to understand
function as well dynamics and that's
just our key to understanding life
everybody knows for the microscope is
better how does this one look like it's
a big blue box that is I think in here
three four times be taller than we are
and and then there is a chamber where
one place is a sample and then it's
illuminated inside there's vacuum inside
and and then there's the camera which is
one of the key components oh they say
they keep components developed most
recently that is they use them to detect
the pictures and monitor it so it's like
a girl taking like a room it's a whole
room yeah and it must be very stable the
floor must be stable because the
sensitive to vibrations and so so it's
it's a big expensive machine there's one
in Stockholm which is shared between
Stockholm University and other
universities and it's I love love and
then there's fun in email so yes we do
use it we just started recently because
it's the instrument is no because there
we we do use it in my research also I
think a lot of people are really
interested in using the instrument
because it can provide so much
information that is it's it's very
important for understanding function so
what would be your dream discovery at
this moment I think for for the future I
mean first of all it is to see the
molecules we work on that's in itself
it's
it's something very warm rewarding to be
able to see the objects you work on but
I think for the for the future and which
is now more and more become possible
Lister to observe as I mentioned before
these different states that one can
freeze the sample while freeze the the
molecules why they do something to
actually combine the information into a
movie or they understand the dynamics
how how they interact what they do how
what what happens in inside the cell I
mean this is with purified proteins of
course but one can venom I've tried to
understand what happens inside the cell
is really there any more secrets that
are not revealed in the living cell
animal and not yet because the technique
or the style at the status is relatively
new so the possibilities to use this
technique to in this way way that is
used today it has only been possible
since just a couple of years so I think
now it's an explosion and a research and
what is limiting now it's its access to
the microscope actually
so it's a waiting time it's very long I
think with no new microscopes and more
microscopes I think I'm there there's a
lot to be seen
there's also a very long way to develop
this one it's like since 70s or 80s what
was the main obstacle I think it's I
mean from the beginning the problem was
that studies of biological objects in an
electron microscope it's not trivial
because there is vacuum inside which the
biological samples contain primarily
water so they dry inside and shape
changes and the pictures are useless
then electron beam burns the molecules
which also changes the structure even
more dramatically and this has been a
challenge to to to be able to reduce the
intensity of electrons of the radiation
and yet to be able to see something in
the background noise and this required
both techniques for phone and developing
the microscope the technology itself but
also techniques to to be able to find
the molecules in the pictures because
the machines one has to reduce the
irradiation the light in the course
prevalent to life in electro a light
microscope a theory electrons and then
the pictures are very weak so one has to
find the what objects are one has to see
how they are related to each other in in
a space and this requires mathematical
method mathematical tools and computer
programs and this of course the sample
preparation to be able to freeze the
samples in such a way that the picture
is not distorted so all they have been
research has been going on very actively
during a long time but has there's been
a lot to do before the technique my
children to the distance today not to
kill the life in this
in the molecule serum there is this very
special way of freezing the water the
solution yes divided waters yes yes so
the idea is that in one freeze normally
when one freezes water ice crystals are
formed and ice crystals diffract
electrons so that the information is
lost because the electrons go diffracted
always so the idea was to to freeze the
water so fast that the crystals would
not have time to form so and this is
called vitrified water or a like a glass
it's the same principle as glass in a
window it's also a liquid all the
molecules are disordered and they are
they are not crystallized but because
it's like a liquid that is like a solid
but it's actually on windows you can see
in the lower part of all all the houses
the windows a little bit thicker and
it's the same way here yes right right
and so it means the same way here freeze
water so far rapidly that that the
crystals don't have time to be formed
and it's it's like a uniform glass that
is transparent or actually it does
interact with electrons but in a uniform
way and this allowed the technique to be
developed such that contrast could be
increased and anyone could see the
molecules
in the pictures in electron microscope I
understand so now you have a perfect
instrument would you like to modify a
tourism or to do I think them the new
detectors which was the latest
breakthrough they are not perfect there
is still a lot to do to improve them
also the sample preparation methods
could be improved way the cryo stage and
the weather or kept that the temperature
is kept constant because the variation
in the temperature can cause movement so
so there are lot of techniques and also
I mean it's in principle very little
sample is needed to for the studies but
since one has to apply a droplet to this
grid one has to remove almost all the
sample and very very small fraction such
a droplet in a bathtub that is actually
left so if one could develop techniques
that would allow applying very small
amounts of samples and there is of
course my many more molecules that could
be studied because it's not possible to
to purify all molecules in animal at an
amount that is allowed studies so there
are not a lot of pieces that can be
improved and I think for the future it
will
and I think that technique has locked
promise
and my last question perhaps what did
the Lord say when they got the call from
Stockholm but from what lady we had some
problems with with the telephone line
but not that I heard were very happy and
surprised and looking forward to coming
to Stockholm in December
thank you
you